and welcome to Hannity and tonight we
are broadcasting live from the grand old
opri right here in beautiful Nashville
Tennessee which is the site of the fifth
annual Patriot Awards by the way that
kicks off tomorrow you don't want to
miss it 6:30 p.m. only on Fox Nation and
coming up by the way the one and only
Kid Rock right here on our set that's
going to be a lot of fun but we do begin
tonight on the west coast where the
president of the United States he just
wrapped up a series of high stakes
meetings with the dictator of China
president shei now this after months of
begging and pleading and begging and ass
kissing well anyway America's
relationship with China has severely
deteriorated since Joe Biden's has
become president and frankly for good
reason China we all know infected the
world with covid-19 a disease that
killed more than a million Americans
there has never been any accountability
they continue to ship massive quantities
of cheap fentanyl to North America that
is a drug that is killing 200 of our
fellow Americans every single day again
never held accountable they threaten our
allies including Taiwan and the
Philippines constantly flying into
Taiwan airspace constantly they conduct
hostile Maneuvers around our military
aircraft in international airspace they
confront our Navy in international
waters and Joe Biden does nothing and of
course they buy cheap gas and oil from
Russia and Iran to make them
rich and coal from North Korea that new
AIS of evil now they steal our
intellectual property they use unfair
Trade Practices and our country is
frankly stupid enough to actually
allowed communist Chinese Nationals to
come into our country and buy thousands
and thousands of Acres of farmland and
thousands of thousands of Acres of Ranch
Land and also land around our military
bases now by the way Donald Trump he
challenged them he confronted them he
warned them he put massive tariffs never
before done on them and guess what they
didn't do all of this when America had a
strong president and of course they spy
on Americans including the bizarre spy
balloon incident where a massive
floating object equipped with
surveillance equipment oh went for well
over a week you know traversing all
across the United States over even our
military installations um I'm pretty
sure Donald Trump would not have allowed
that to happen either and would have
shot that plane that that air balloon
down much sooner now there are some
things that you may not know for
starters China's economy it is now a
dumpster fire its Draconian zero Co
policies has taken a serious toll on the
country its real estate market is
basically in a full collapse they've had
a massive population it is in a steep
Decline and it's once growing middle
class that is now imploding as a result
China is more dangerous than ever
president Chi is desperately looking for
a win and with a pathetically weak US
president at the helm well what better
time than right now because here's Joe
Biden from earlier today he looked very
very very sleepy
Joey I've never doubted what you've told
me in terms of your candidate nature in
which you speak I value our conversation
because I think it's Paramount that you
and I understand each other clearly
leader to leader with no misconceptions
or
miscommunication we also have a
responsibility to our people and the
work in the world uh to work together
when we see it in our interest to do so
and a critical Global challenge we Face
from climate change to counternarcotics
to artificial intelligence demand our
joint
efforts Hey Joe I promise you president
she China they don't care about climate
change and they think you're stupid for
paying all the money with the Paris
climate Accords now Biden followed up
that performance with a very short
lackluster press conference just moments
ago where he called on pre-selected
reporters hold on let me let me call
from um they told me to call on Joe okay
and then of course responded to their
questions by reading pre-written answers
how convenient take a look and that's uh
now I'd like to be able to take some
questions if I may and I'm told that
Dimitri of the financial times has the
first
question uh next question sorry was
Bloomberg uh you know uh we're in a
situation where we agreed that uh
Fentanyl and his prec his precursors
will be curbed substantially and the
pill presses that's a big that's a big
movement uh I'm embarrassed I think it's
CBS but I can't remember who in CBS I'm
sorry uh Mr President good day sorry I
apologize uh what do you got Washington
Post I think that's
right Mr oh there you are sorry I
couldn't see in the
light got to cut Joey some slack now
it's way past his bedtime that's usually
700 p.m. Eastern and he's not used to
traveling either and to make matters
worse well more concessions from Biden
today he agreed to limit the use of
artificial intelligence technology in
America's military and China is
threatening to invade our Ally Taiwan
and we're agreeing to limit our military
capabilities uh not a good idea experts
accusing Biden of giving up what is a
massive strategic advantage and calling
his deal with President XI an incredibly
poor decision now let's just say uh I'll
be kind about this he's rather dumb
naive and stupid and it looks like that
he wants more multi million doll deals
with China for him and his family and
his son Hunter now when will Biden ever
stand up for America First is even
capable of making a right decision now
keep in mind what we told you last night
now just this week Joe Biden this week
freed up another $10 billion for the
mullers in Iran the number one State
sponsors of Terror yeah the same Iran
involved in the biggest terrorist attack
in Israel's history and this this is by
the way this also after a growing number
of attacks against our soldiers in the
Middle East and that most experts beli
they had a hand in and today a US
Destroyer targeted during a a drone
attack from an Iranian proxy in Yemen so
how did Joe respond well as per usual he
did nothing America's enemies get
favorable deals and by the way Cold Hard
Cash American soldiers they get shot at
and nobody defends them is anyone
surprised that Biden's approval rating
just got even lower a Quinn Pak poll
just came out Biden only has a 37%
approval rating and so tonight as Biden
is limping towards 2024 what can we
expect from China in the coming weeks
and the coming months hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else